it's Friday July 1110 it's Friday July
tenth I'm Chris waters Rob here it's gia
snooze top ten stories Rob here with gia
snooze top five stories of the week
we're gonna take a look at all the crazy
stories that we had this week starting
with Monday moving on all tuesday
wednesday thursday friday all through
the week its goal the number one
so unfortunately we do not get any free
DLC for the witcher 3 this week no
instead we got the latest details on a
big patch coming out next week parade
developer CD Projekt RED released some
details about the 1.07 patch earlier
this week describing it as very large
some of the highlights to the patch were
a new alternative movement response to
Gerald various inventory sorting and
organizing options and improvements to
the horse behavior I think we all can
agree Roach had a drug problem look how
high is CD Projekt RED also stated this
week that the upcoming paid expansion
for Witcher 3 will add 30 more hours of
content to the game according to almost
the size of 2011's The Witcher 2 also
this week youtuber PewDiePie's earnings
were released for 2014 how much a lot
7.5 million wicked dad wait what though
popular youtuber PewDiePie
unsurprisingly received some negative
comments regarding his YouTube moolah
and has recently spoken out about his
earnings stating money is the topic that
I purposely try to avoid for the five
years that I've been making videos
because I just I just feel like it's not
important to anyone and I just want to
make entertaining videos totally I
understand that people just haters gonna
hate right but I don't know I i really
think that money doesn't make you happy
PewDiePie currently has 37 million
subscribers and is believed to generate
more than 4 million in ad sales per year
in 2014 he raised six hundred and thirty
thousand dollars for the Save the
Children charity also this week we got
the details on the new Playstation 4
being told it's quieter and more power
efficient than the earlier models the
new ps4 rocks a one terabyte hard drive
doubling the previous ps4 waist ten
percent less and uses eight percent less
energy oh and the hard drive cover has a
matte finish instead of a glossy one
damn so neat getting crazy also this
week the win
ters of the best of e3 2015 Game Critics
Awards have been announced and who do
you think won Best in Show you guessed
it fallout 4 that's right Bethesda's
fallout 4 takes the big win from e3 2015
as well as wins for best pc game and
best RPG star wars battlefront which
originally had the most nominations
walked away with best action game and
best online multiplayer and this week's
top story brings breaking news the
infamous hacking group lizard squad has
d dost daybreak games it all started
with the sentencing of 17 year-old
Julius give Mackey for more than 50,000
charges in cyber crimes finland's court
sentenced Julius to a two-year
suspension with no prison time a
punishment that John Smedley CEO of
daybreak games did not agree with
smedley over Twitter recounted having
his flight grounded in 2014 due to a
bomb threat an axe lizard squad took
responsibility for smedley stated I'm
coming for you Julius then stated I may
go after his parents in civil court to
little dirtbag in retaliation lizard
squad has attacks daybreak games writing
on Twitter last night smedley
acknowledged that every day break games
such as h1z1 and planetside 2 have been
affected by the two attacks lizard squad
tweeted hope you liked our present john
smedley smedley has since made a
statement on reddit regarding the
attacks and frustration on the matter
yet he says he is still adamant on
bringing those associated with lizard
squad to jail and that's it from me
thank God right will you stay tuned to
next week 4gs news with Jess McDonald
and if you don't get her you're gonna
get Chris waters if you don't get Chris
waters you're gonna get married Kish if
you don't get married Kish you get out
you how so here legit yo that's it see
ya how does that lamp shade it again
oh [ __ ]